hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
ein video ich habe heute die zwei dabei
erobern guten tag
und ja wir haben uns für heute überlegt
wir machen so eine challenge im jahr
also es geht halt darum ich habe
aussagen rausgesucht high court aussagen
rausgesucht du auch mit thesen ja
genauso halt richtig oder falsch wäre es
darauf antwort operiert ob die richtig
und das eine lüge so ernst die nichte
und wenn man halt falsch liegt dann
kassiert man werde hier sehen was wir
meinen so manchmal wirklich okay okay
erste aussage 2015 starben mehr menschen
durch selbst hals durch haiangriffe ja
stimmt so alles du bist dran gemacht
auch pinguine können bis zu zwei meter
hoch springen
das englische wort hund dabei wunderbar
wunderbar heißt wohl gestern als auch
morgen ja falsch das heißt ja ich habe
mir das nicht mehr fast nichts zu tun
jetzt kommt der kampf jetzt will ich bin
ich immer noch hier
namen gehabt nicht bei uns musste ich
meine kranken weil wir in der scheiße
kommen in dem fall aufgenommen bin
gesprungen und hatte anscheinend hat er
weggezogen war dagegen alles angeschaut
der kodex wurde da war war das wieder
gut soll ich da hatte kühlbehälter
gefangen
wenn du das wirklich doppelt so reich
in japan gibt es eine waschmaschine für
hunde und katzen sauber sind wenn
gebraten
top
wo sich deutsche sport ist so nicht
richtig behindert
aber ok wat ausgleichen in den 80er
jahren wurde eine kröte entdeckt die
maut und schreit er uns nicht schreibt
die haut falten sind einfach fünf von
sechs toren gewinnen stylischer alko
laut einer was laut einer studie
steigert aspelin die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass männer fremdgehen aspirin wird das
blut der und das blut fließt also mit
eines jährig wir bringen dich ein
erneutes was würdest du das weniger pro
jahr ebenfalls keine ahnung weshalb witz
der alles ist was im roman frage wo man
das so ja okay das älteste spermium der
welt ist 20 millionen jahre alt ja noch
ich habe das gemacht dass es sogar über
50 millionen es über 20 uhr st
ich habe gesagt dass else schwert in der
welt ist 20 millionen zuseher und habe
ich 26 millionen jahre alt du hast dich
hier trauen ist
hallo
also man sieht sie auf einer hand ab
am heftigsten geschwollen treffen die
kommentare man bei einer online-studie
übersetzte doris man sich viele leute
das war's mit diesem video zeigt auch
auf jeden fall das video blogs update
oder abonniert ihr auch bassist
unterstellte ersteinlage das ist heute
abonniert an alex kommt noch einiges auf
jeden und erleichtert ich diesen blog
mit noch wieder tür